- All right, so I am so
excited because we are here,
it is Tuesday, May 29th 2018,
and this is Manhattanhenge.
This is Dr. Neil deGrasse Tyson,
your personal astrophysicist
and the man who named
the event where we are, Manhattanhenge.
- Okay, so I called it
to everyone's attention
- Okay.
- Of course this has been going on
since the grid has been up
but no body has been paying
attention, you know why?
- Why?
- First it has to be clear.
- Okay.
- But second, you have to
be crossing the street,
- Okay.
- And not concerned about your health
and well-being while
you're crossing the street.
- As evidenced by the number of people
who are in the middle of the street!
- [Neil] Right.
And you have to be on one of the two days
in which this is going on.
- Right.
- And I knew such a day
would exist. I calculated it.
My first shot of Manhattanhenge
was on this very
intersection of Park Avenue
and 34th Street.
The beautiful Empire State Building,
there it is right there, you check it out.
Empire State Building.
- Yeah baby.
- [Neil] There you go.
- New York, New York state of mind.
- New York state of mind.
Okay, so then I publish
my first photo of it.
- Okay.
- And then people started
gathering in the streets
and I said, "Look,
traffic has been stopped
for like Con-Ed digging holes."
- Right.
- For all, for you know
pedestrians getting hit by cars.
- Right.
- I figured let the traffic stop
because the people want
to drink in the Cosmos.
- Very nice.
- Yes yes yes.
And what such event is the alignment
of the sunset on the Manhattan grid.
- Where did you get the
name Manhattanhenge?
- As a kid I visited Stonehenge
I was very impressed.
- [Chuck] Very nice.
- [Neil] With the fact
that ancient peoples
made these vertical stone monuments and
Stonehenge itself is
actually an observatory
and no one knew that until like
an astronomer figured that out.
People said, "Oh they're
worshiping the sun,"
"and they're this and
the druids and whatever."
This is a frickin observatory
that can predict eclipses.
Okay? Just because they're ancient people
don't mean they're stupid.
- Well that is true.
And just because we're modern people
doesn't mean we're smart.
- Thank you.
- Yes.
- Oh, we got a bus coming.
- Oh bus.
- We in the bus lane.
- It's like we're playing
football back in the hood.
(laughs)
- And so now like thousands of people
pour into the street and stop
traffic for a cosmic reason.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah yeah I'm totally into that.
- This is your baby, you got to be proud.
- I'm proud now. So this
happens twice a year.
The same number of days before the
June solstice.
- Right.
- As after. One of our
challenges is in summertime,
we get, as is true for
most of the country.
We get our weather from the
states that sit west of us.
So our weather comes from
New Jersey. From New Jersey.
- Bus.
- And so if there's like storms
and things over New Jersey--
If there's storms over New Jersey,
the sun will set behind the storms
and we get no Manhattanhenge.
So I'm worried about that,
there's some cloud action over there.
New Jersey might be messing with us again.
Oh, another bus coming.
So you notice how anytime we
dig up old civilizations--
- Yes.
- We say, oh they worship the sun
and this is their sun culture.
So I'm imagining the day
where apocalyptic earth,
and they dig up the grid of Manhattan.
Okay. And then they try to figure out
'why was it aligned this way?'
So if you look at what is
happening in American Culture
on those two days, okay?
The first of the Manhattanhenges
happens around Memorial Day.
The second one, happens--.
The second one happens near
baseball's All Star Break.
- Oh
So future anthropologists
would surely judge
that we align Manhattan in honor
of the two things
America cares most about.
- War, and baseball.
(laughing)
It's that simple.
We're America, we love war and baseball.
- War and baseball.
So what's going on is,
people say, oh watch this--
What direction does the sun rise?
- It sets in the east, so
it must rise in the west.
- So both of them are wrong.
The sun rises in the
east and sets in the west
on only two days a year.
- Okay.
- And those are on the equinoxes,
March 21st and September 21st.
- And why is that?
- And every other day of the year,
the sun is rising and
setting somewhere else
on the horizon, okay?
- But why is that?
- I did a little Trump thing here.
- Somewhere else.
Somewhere fantastic.
- So before today.
- Bus bus.
- The buses butt is in the way.
So what happens is the
sun is setting at an angle
and before today, before today,
it has set south of this aligned street.
So you would never see the sunset.
- Right?
- Beginning today, you see the
sun cross this field of view.
And today it's setting on the grid.
Tomorrow, it's gonna set
a little farther north
and a little farther north
and it'll keep doing that until June 21st.
First day of Summer.
Lemme finish.
- Okay, go ahead.
Come to the north and it
sets its farthest point north
on June 21st.
- Okay.
- After that, it starts --
and the sun slows down, stops,
that's why it's called solstice.
- Right.
- Latin for stationary sun.
So, after that it starts
setting backwards again.
And it re-appears here and
this would be around July 11th.
- [Chuck] Uh-oh, police.
They're worse than the bus.
Back up to the sidewalk,
back up to the sidewalk.
By the way, you not supposed
to be in the bus lane, officer!
Excuse me, officer!
You not supposed to be in the bus lane!
Okay.
- Why didn't you say
that when he was closer?
- Well you know, 'cause I'm a coward.
- So there you have it, Manhattanhenge.
It looks like we're not getting it.
- We're not gonna get it
because of the clouds.
- New Jersey took Manhattanhenge from us.
They put a cloud in the way.
- [Chuck] And that's the
sun right behind that cloud.
- Jersey did it! Curse you, New Jersey!
- [Chuck] If you look--
- Chuck lives in New Jersey.
- I do, it's my fault.
(laughing)